brenna are dolls joining us from
Northwestern as we're talking to us
about robots learning from motor
impaired teachers thanks Andrea for the
introduction and thanks to the
organizers for the invitation so as
Andrea mentioned I'm from northwestern
university i have three departmental
affiliations there ecs mechanical and
engineering and then PM NRS physical
medicine and rehabilitation so that's in
the medical school my lab is actually at
the Rehabilitation Institute of Chicago
which is a hospital a rehabilitation
hospital in downtown Chicago at Ric we
treat a variety of motor impairments and
some cognitive impairments as well we do
less in the area of sensory impairments
but a little bit and Ric has been named
the number one rehab hospital in the
country for 26 consecutive years so what
that means for me as an engineering
researcher and those of us the rest of
us who are engineering researchers there
is that we have access to a really rich
patient population richer than we would
see in the Chicago area naturally if we
weren't pulling people from sort of
around the world and then also we have
very easy and ready access to expertise
of clinical staff and clinicians and
therapists and that really helps to sort
of guide and focus our work and keep it
focused on solutions that are sort of
like deployable tomorrow instead of
depending on technologies that might not
be available for 10 years something like
that so when I came to Ric I was coming
from a background in robotics autonomy
I'd never worked in the space of
assistive or rehab robotics and what
became clear I was trying to find an
intersection for a place for autonomy to
sort of make an impact in this domain so
there is robotics already within the
field of rehabilitation but at least
clinically there's not higher level
autonomy so we tend to see sort of
therapy machines that are replacing or
augmenting what a physical therapist
were to already do or we see wearable
robots like exoskeletons and prosthesis
so this idea of sort of higher level
autonomy we don't really see clinically
within within rehabilitation so in
trying to come and see where there might
be a place for autonomy to have impact
it became pretty clear very quickly that
there are a lot of assistive machines
that we see with in rehabilitation that
are used by people who engage in
rehabilitation that are difficult for
those people to operate precisely
because of their motor impairments so if
we take as an example of the powered
wheelchair
that's by far the most ubiquitous
assistive machine and that's a two
dimensional control problems you control
heading in your control speed that's
very easily covered by a to access
joystick and if you're able to operate
it to access joystick a wheelchair very
quickly becomes the natural extension of
your body's own mobility now if you
don't have that kind of hand function
there are alternative interfaces
available to you and the most common are
what's called a headrest it switches
that are embedded with them the head
rest of the wheelchair so you sort of
press backwards to go forwards you'd
usually do like a double tap in order to
go backwards and then you tap right and
left in order to go right and left now
in terms of the quality of our control
signal the differences are that these
are now issued in one dimension at a
time so you don't get a nice continuous
valued 2d control signal you get one
dimension at a time and it's discreet so
it's like turning a switch on and off so
you control your forward motion or you
control your turning one at a time and
if you want to go faster you actually
have to normally like sort of navigate
back through this little interface
there's normally a small screen on the
side of the wheelchair to navigate back
through this interface in order to
choose a different power level there
tend to be four power levels another
common interface is the sip and puff so
if anyone's ever seen someone driving a
powered wheelchair he was like a straw
based interface that's a similar similar
sort of mechanism now there are sort of
tricks with these interfaces to issue a
2d signal at a time but you're actually
normally kind of like latching that
signal and you're not actively
controlling it anymore it's just
continuing to issue what you did before
while you know issue conceptual signals
another dimension so that makes
wheelchair driving more difficult but
it's feasible I mean if you have to take
a 2d control problem is sort of parse it
into 1d discrete increments it's a bit
more challenging but it's manageable now
if we take for example a robotic arm
that's meant to be mounted to a powered
wheelchair these are do exist
commercially now so that arm in
particulars from canova robotics which
is a canadian company and to just
position the end effector of a robotic
arm is a 60 problem so you have position
in 3d and you have orientation in 3d now
even if you're using sort of this to
access joystick right that actually only
controls a fraction of this control
problem this arm is actually sold with a
3d joystick so it additionally has twist
but that still is only half of the
control space at a given time you see
that this man is actually operating the
joystick with his foot so one of the big
sort of comfy
pounds or paradoxes I would actually say
with these kind of with operating
robotic arms is that if you need
assistance from a robotic arm you would
probably don't have the hand function to
operate this kind of joystick certainly
not with twisting and yet those are the
people who arguably need the help the
most it's it's the or one who would
benefit the most from this sort of
assistance so we have this sort of this
paradox where the more motor impaired
you are the more complex assistance you
need so maybe you need this robotic arm
instead of just the wheelchair and yet
the less able you are to issue the more
complex control signals that that
assistant or that machine requires and
so this is an opportunity for robotics
autonomy so here's an example of what
those interfaces look like so on the
left that's the head array and on the
right that's the sip and puff so this is
an opportunity for robotics autonomy
just to sort of recap the control
challenges I was just talking about so
we have these limited interfaces that no
longer span the full control space of
the machine we're trying to operate and
do it in a more discreet in low
information content boy we have motor
impairments of the person so independent
regardless of what interface they're
using their ability to operate that
interface is hampered by the fact that
we have this motor impairment that's
sort of filtering their few their true
motor intent and then we have machine
complexity that the more complex these
machines get the more complicated they
are to control and the less compatible
they are with these limited control
interfaces so as I mentioned this is an
opportunity for robotics autonomy so in
particular as we have taken robots out
of factory spaces where they had very
known environments and they basically
had no autonomy into human environments
we've had to come up with synthetic ways
to sense the world and reason about it
and take action within it and what we
would like to do is leverage those
approaches to help address these sensory
cognitive and motor impairments these
gaps that are left by sensory Mart
cognitive and motor impairments in
humans in order to assist them in
operating these assistive machines so in
order to turn an assistive machine into
a robot at a high level it's fairly
straightforward so you first need to add
on sensing capability so that it can
detect things in the environment around
it and possibly also information about
the human that's operating it then we
add on computing and artificial
intelligence that could reason about
what it's sensed and also
the signals that it's getting from the
human and then we've turned it into an
assistive robot now all of these control
challenges as i mentioned earlier are
also challenges for the autonomy as well
and we haven't one additional factor as
well that i hadn't mentioned yet and
this is the fact that each of our users
has unique and non-static abilities so
they're unique because every motor
impairment is different and also
everyone has different personal
preferences and how they might want to
interact with autonomy non-static our
abilities is because we know that our
humans are going to be changing so it
might be that they are in rehabilitation
and they're regaining ability which is
what we hope for it could be that they
have a degenerative disease and they're
losing ability which is not what we hope
for but it is a reality of this domain
or it could just be that factors like
fatigue or pain throughout the day or
week to week have a role in how they
operate the machine and also in what
kind of assistance that they would like
to have and so we need to be taking this
into consideration as well so to start
out we should be customizing this
autonomy to individual users which is a
really big big thing to take on in the
robotic wheelchair that we've been
developing in my lab we've prioritized
two things so one is customization for
the reasons that I just mentioned and
then the other is low cost and this is
because we don't expect this is going to
be covered by insurance or Medicare and
Medicaid anytime soon when a purpose
fills out a form when a therapist fits a
person with a powered wheelchair they
actually fill out a stack of forms this
thick to justify every seating cushion
every single possible decision you would
make in customizing this wheelchair to
that person has to be justified in order
to be reimbursed by insurance so we are
not going to be reimbursed into it by
insurance until we get on to that form
and in order to get on to that form you
need to have a lot of proof of having
this kind of efficacy so our goal and I
will consider to the I will consider
autonomy in in wheelchairs to have sort
of made it when it shows up on a
rehabilitation for or sorry
reimbursement forms that you will be
able to say with this these kind of
motor impairments this person would
benefit from this kind of autonomy and
to get that they need this kind of
software and these kind of sensors but
that we are not expecting is going to
happen anytime soon so one way that we
accustom
accomplished customization is with a
modular software paradigm so we can have
any number of assistance modules that
the person can sort of opt into or opt
out of we also have a modular Hardware
structure our idea is that someone comes
to us with their powered wheelchair and
control interface we don't introduce
custom control interfaces that might
give us richer information in part
because we're not interface design
experts but also because these control
interfaces have been widely vetted by
the popular community or the larger
community and even if they are subpar in
many different ways they're widely
vetted and the covered by insurance so
what we want to do is do the best job
that we can do in software with the kind
of crappy control it control signals
that we get from these interfaces so the
idea is that you need to add on
computing power and electronics we
actually draw from the power on the
wheelchair but we have to have an
inverter and then our base system just
has one RGB d sensor now if we add on
additional sensors we add on robustness
we add on capabilities it might be that
some of those software modules that I
introduced on the prior slide require
some sort of more complex sensor the
idea is that you can get away with just
one RGB sensor and get some assistance
and then people could choose to add on
additional sensors add additional costs
but also add additional capabilities
based on what their needs might be now
another way within software that we're
accomplishing customization is in the
way that we actually do control sharing
so when we have an autonomous system of
course it's going to have an idea of
what the wheelchair should do and then
the human is still issuing control
signals about what they think the
wheelchair should do and how to actually
reason about those two signals and
create a single a single signal is
something that is I would argue
understudied in the field and widely
variable and it's something that needs a
lot of needs a lot of attention in order
for users to actually accept these
machines so that we've seen in a lot of
different medical domains that when
people feel like some sort of machine is
doing too much for them or is
unanticipated on how it's doing
something they just reject the
technology entirely so getting this
right is going to be one of the sort of
Lynch pins for this kind of technology
alpha value then something the user
could yes I'm going to be getting today
so so there's a couple of different ways
to sort of customize the control sharing
so this is just a sort of simple linear
blending paradigm this is what we see a
lot now actually in robotic wheelchair
research we've seen paradigms that
aren't blending like this but normally
and so there's there's a bunch of
different ways to sort of formulate it
but then within a given formulation of
course you can play with parameters and
that's one of the ways that we can
accomplish this customization is by
introducing these sort of tunable knobs
then how to actually tune them is a big
question and I'll talk about that in a
little bit yeah that's what we'd like to
get to eventually now of course there's
a risk there that if you adapt to
quickly it becomes unanticipated and
gets rejected if you DEP to slowly then
you're not meeting their needs and so
exactly how to do that is a huge
question and actually i'll be talking
about that towards the end we recently
won a long like five-year grant just to
do that and we're starting out by just
gathering tons of teleoperation data on
a robotic wheelchair and a robotic arm
with people with a variety of motor
impairments and people without any motor
impairments to start to cystic
statistically analyze how there are
differences in where and come up with
algorithms that are gonna be able to
appropriately adapt from that but we're
just starting at work so okay so the
first oh the first part of my talk is
going to be about sharing control
between humans and assistive robots so I
just mentioned that blending is one way
this sort of blending is one way to
accomplish control sharing so I'm going
to kind of sort of step through what are
the different pieces of providing
assistance or coming up with these
autonomous systems so in these diagrams
the green outline is the footprint of
the robot the red arrow is the control
signal coming from the human user the
gray box is an obstacle and that line at
the top with a gap the gap represents a
doorway so the first thing not on I mean
these it needs is some kind of a goal it
can't provide any assistance is if it
has no idea what's going on or what the
humans trying to do so one way to do
this is to actually oops okay one way to
do this is just sort to sort of forward
project into the future like a half a
second the current control command and
this has sort of the fewest
assumptions placed on what the human is
trying to do so that could be sort of
like a temporary sub-goal in our system
of course we could also have a higher
level perception system that's able to
detect places where people who are the
human tends to need assistance so
spatially constrained spaces like
doorways we have a perception algorithm
that is able to detect doorways just
with the deaths data in an RGB d camera
we also can detect docking locations at
desks and at tables and we can even
anchor those locations to circular like
place settings if that because of course
there's like an infinite number of
places you could choose if it's all free
and for all of these we check for
clearance and safety and things like
that so of course now if you've had now
if you possibly have more than one
candidate location in the in the
environment that you could go to you
have to figure out which to go to and
that's typically called intent inference
within the field of robotics research so
if you watch here my left thumb I am
telly operating the wheelchair robot and
I'm driving it towards two doors and
right now my signals are ambiguous it's
not clear which doorway I want and it's
that I have to sort of give the signal a
little bit to the left before it's
ambiguous or it's disambiguated and now
when i stop providing a control signal
it'll actually go through the door so
one of the first things we need to so
first we have to be able to perceive
goals in the first place then we need a
way to sort of arbitrate between those
goals once we've done that we can
actually come up with an autonomous
signal so here if we now say that this
is the goal we want now we can have the
autonomy come up with a safe path that
reaches that goal without having an
illusion and then that gives us at this
current time step the autonomy control
signal which is the blue arrow so now
we've got these two control signals and
we need to decide between them so one
way to decide then between them is
something we call filtering but this is
something we've seen in the literature
come up with multiple different groups
and this is that you just cap the users
control signal to not exceed what the
autonomy would issued in either
dimension in order to keep it safe and
then that would mean that we get an
executed signal of that purple that
purple arrow yep so how
save for okay is there to do these
extrapolations because maybe nine times
out of ten if I'm heading towards the
door I do plan to actually go through
the role but maybe one time out of 10 I
do plan to just stop before the door
maybe pick up something on the floor or
so so is it always okay to extrapolate
that if I'm closer to Rygel moving
towards a guideline I mean it depends
how you formulated this intent inference
so I didn't talk about it in the prior
slip fit on the prior slide but actually
it for us it's a it's a combination of
how far we are from that goal whether or
not we're sort of oriented towards it
and also whether or not how the extent
to which the human signal agrees with
doing that and so and then lots of time
we have formulations where if you the
human stops giving signal it just stops
so in that case like if the human wanted
to stop and pick it up they can we do
have formulations though where the human
stops it's actually a queue if we're
really close to it and we're really
confident that that's what they want to
do it's actually cute that the autonomy
should just take over and again this
would be something that's customizable
that humans can choose the user can
choose what sort of paradigm they are
most comfortable with kind of like you
did are you or others also investigating
like adding any speech modality so
getting additional information from the
human is a possibility like I said we're
starting from this sort of ground up
where we're trying to see what we can do
so that it feels like someone is just
driving the chair as they would normally
drive the chair and there's just it's
you can think of it kind of as like
driver assist so this is not driverless
cars this is like Lane Assist and
collision avoidance and parking assist
things like that I'm sure there's
obviously a lot more we can do you know
we can add in GPS we can do all
different sorts of things but we're
trying to do is start at the base and
build it up and see what gets requested
and needed instead of starting the top
with what robotics can do and trying to
back propagate it and match it to what
humans might need the other direction
like could the wheelchair tell the user
what that what yeah
oh yeah yeah absolutely so that's
another and that's another thing that
exactly how the right way to interface
that and introduce it in a way that's
not too overly distracting to the human
and not overly annoying like that the
robots not constantly asking for
confirmation I think you want to do this
I think you want to do this right so
getting that right I think it's pretty
clear that some information is going to
be better than no information but
certainly there can be too much
information and so that's I'd say a
whole nother research area yeah okay so
another way to do this control sharing
is the blending paradigm that you saw
earlier the equation you saw earlier so
that was just a simple sort of linear
linear equation and so in this case the
purple arrow becomes sort of a mixture
of these two and we can check that the
purple arrow is still going to avoid
collisions right so here's an example
actually of what that can look like this
is something that we just have running
all the time actually under as a safety
layer underneath in the wheelchair so
again if you watch my thumb I'm trying
to drive directly into the chair and the
robot drives around it but you see it
doesn't try to like return to this
position afterwards we're not making a
lot of assumptions about what the humans
trying to do we just sort of nudge them
out of the way while there's a dangerous
situation and then we give them back
control and you can see that here so
this color is actually that alpha
parameter we saw earlier and so that's
dictating how much controls with the
human versus the robot so when when it's
red that is zero control with the human
and when it's green there's a hundred
percent control in the human for
computational reasons we sort of pick
increments of alpha and we just sort of
tune this ourselves to something that
felt pretty natural but ran fast enough
to run in real time on the robot
okay now of course we can also do this
blending with our perception goal our
higher level goal right in which case
now the purple arrow would be pushing us
kind of much more to the left than it
did before because the machine is making
is inferring that the human actually
wants to try to go through the door
which in this case maybe wouldn't be the
right decision based on the control
signal that the human is giving but this
isn't just a pictorial depiction of what
that might look like and then we can do
this same sort of thing at a little bit
more of an aggressive way where we just
sort of do blending until we're near a
sort of high-level goal and we're really
close and the human stops giving a
signal we take that as a cue just take
me through a hundred percent
autonomously which on we know that full
autonomy is not a good solution for
users that they've it's been shown
through multiple different studies
different kinds of platforms that that's
not what people want but whether or not
they occasionally want one hundred
percent autonomy we're actually starting
to see in our studies that sometimes
they do just for small short segments of
times and when it's pretty unambiguous
what it is that they're trying to do
like going through the doorway if it's
in here oh I mean it might be tricky
Ashley yeah signaling to get it with
that just exactly and I'll show some
video of that actually as well
especially with these limited interfaces
it can be really hard to do these
spatially constraint test to get through
the doorway I think that in our
wheelchair we've got about 10
centimeters clearance total and so
that's on each side so if you're
perfectly centered that's five
centimeters on each side so it's pretty
tight okay so as I mentioned there have
it so there have been a lot of a lot of
different ways to accomplish this
control sharing in the literature these
are just some examples there's other
examples as well and what we have seen
is often a comparison between no
autonomy so just one hundred percent
human control and full autonomy or full
autonomy and partial autonomy and that's
where we see that partial autonomy tends
to be really really preferred what we
haven't really seen is the fact that
there's so many different ways to
formulate partial autonomy and actually
a study that compares them and sees if
people can actually see the difference
between members have preference between
them things like that so that's exactly
a study that we've just finished up in
my lab so in this study we had five
different control paradigms so we
basically had before I presented on the
prior slide plus full teleoperation
we had two different interfaces so we
had a head array so that was where the
switches are in the headrest and we had
a joystick so we had a 1d discrete
interface and a 2d continuous value
interface we had the study happened in
two to four sessions so we thought it
would just be two sessions but for some
of our motor impaired subjects they only
have a sitting tolerance of about an
hour and a half and so sometimes we had
to split a given session into two parts
for them and we had seven subjects with
spinal cord injuries and seven subjects
without injuries and what we were doing
was the doorway a doorway traversal test
so it was a spatially constraint task
they basically went from one room in my
lab through a doorway up to the second
door in my lab and then out and then my
postdoc turned them around and then we
did the whole thing in Reverse so it was
for doorway traversals in total so
here's an example of what it looks like
to be just tele operating the wheelchair
with these different interfaces so this
is zero autonomy here on the Left we
have a joystick so this is continuous
valued 2d control and on the right we
have the head array now I should mention
that this subject while he's not
necessarily familiar with our wheelchair
he has been driving a wheelchair for 25
years and for the first 20 years after
his injury so he's at spinal cord injury
he used a head array on the right so
that is an interface that he is familiar
with and then for the last five years
he's been using a joystick modified with
a t-bar as you can see right there so
you can see how how sort of like Speight
painstakingly slow this can be
especially using the interface on the
right to try to actually align properly
and go through the doorway yeah oh the
t-bar is just you see how here he's not
grasping the joystick it's a little hard
to see it's basically that we modify it
to put like a tee on top of it so you
can just kind of do this if you don't
have grip function yeah okay as I
mentioned we had the the five the four
paradigms I talked about earlier plus a
plus teleoperation and here's what it
looks like now with the different
assistance paradigms so I'm sure you can
see a difference between using the
assistance versus not versus the videos
we saw before but you probably can't see
much of a difference between the
different paradigms in terms of how
they're performing and that's what we
actually saw it in our quantitative data
as well well there's not that clear
winner in terms of you know staying the
furthest away from the doorway frame or
going through the fastest things
like that but what we do see is a very
clear preference with the user among
different ones and there's actually not
well actually this will be easier with
my next slide so um so for the
comparative study these results are just
a sneak peek because they're still under
review but I'll just give you a couple
of high high level outputs so one is
that no single single control paradigm
is most preferred across subjects or
performs best with statistical
significance so we asked people with
each interface what was their most
preferred control paradigm at least
preferred and we allowed for ties so
technically they could say I hated all
of them if they wanted at most we
normally Oh saw two ties at the most and
then we asked that for each interface
each paradigm was selected each at least
once and cute including teleoperation
now we did tend to see concentrations of
the distribution with certain paradigms
and we did see differences between the
two subject groups in terms of where
that distribution sort of lay but in
general we can there was no clear winner
there was sort of a clear loser so we
did have a statistically significant
difference in preference and also in
performance for performance in this case
I think was the number of times you had
to interact with the interface and then
also the time it took to complete the
task so filtering seem to actually sort
of be a clear loser that was the one
where you cap the speeds in order to not
exceed the autonomy so I think people
just kind of feel limited by that and
also because you're only over capping
and you're never on menteng of course it
performs slower now that didn't stop at
least one person from picking it but in
general we saw statistically significant
difference it did and some you know and
sometimes there were ties but they
tended to have strong preferences and
that I mentioned that this is a
two-session study we also saw those
those preferences change between
sessions so there's definitely a
familiarity possibly learning factor
happening here and that that would be a
follow-on study that we need to do is a
really actually have a grant in for to
propose that just now to do like a 30
session study just to see once like
learning and familiar it goes away then
do we what do we see okay
these are pretty small sample sizes yes
general it is and you know it's going to
always be specific to our paradigm what
we are kind of taking away from this is
not actually that this says anything
about the individual paradigms but that
this is telling us that we should
provide options on our chair but I mean
of course you can but this is like the
kind of numbers that you would want in
statistics just is not practical in
these kind of domains typically when
when you see like within the
occupational therapy literature and
stuff it actually tends to be case
studies like one-off case studies and
maybe you got two or three and that's
sort of like the state it that's the art
of the field just because of the it's
it's very difficult you know these these
kind of patient populations get very
sick it's just it's very difficult to
work with so yeah statistical
significance aside yes the control
paradigms themselves and the
implementation of control care about
because it might be the case that
example especially some of the more
autonomous of control paradigms are some
of the more difficult actually
implements algorithmically yep maybe the
case is for example you're able to do a
wizard of oz like experiment where
that's feasible but like some human was
able to sort of ya see that and then
this there has been one patient yeah so
I would say it so there has been one
group actually in Canada that did a
study like that and that is the only
other known piece of work we know that
actually even tried to compare different
paradigms I would argue that the
difference between a human and autonomy
doing it is much greater than between
different autonomy paradigms so the
human has you know perfect perception
has all these different sort of all
these different sort of factors that
make it very different than the autonomy
and by having all of this sort of like
blips and everything that you get in
autonomy you get very very different
data and I would it may still not say
anything about the different control
paradigm because the
patience of those control paradigms
might be not be reflective right so
actually these control paradigms are
quite similar to each other in the sense
that we are always using the state we're
computing the goal in the same way we
are computing the path in the same way
so this idea that there's there's a
couple of parameters to tune but not
that many and so and in some cases it's
actually that they're sort of like
iterative to each other it's just kind
of it's just kind of dictating how much
you're taking into consideration the
signal versus that signal so while
autonomy can get very complicated
because this is the autonomy is always
at the same level it's not that some is
like super high level and some is not
the autonomy is always at the same level
and so I would say in terms of
implementation these are actually very
similar in terms of their difficulty so
so I understand what you're saying and I
think it's a good thing to take into
consideration but I actually don't
really think it's a factor at this level
of study okay so another thing is that
what we did see was that preference and
performance both changed with control
interface so while we didn't see a clear
winner we did see both of these changing
when we were using the head array versus
the joystick but we did see that these
performance differences decrease was
sort of increasing autonomy so if we
sort of loosely order our different
control paradigms in terms of how much
the autonomy is stepping in the more
autonomy that steps in the less that we
see differences in performance and
preference with interface and that's
probably because the interface that's
more difficult to operate it becomes
less of a factor that difficulty as you
have more more autonomy helping up and
we also sell performance and preference
change across sessions so this indicates
that there is a human learning factor
and a human familiarity factor as well
so in particular we saw spinal cord
injury subjects switch their preference
about half the time when it was but
using the header a or with the joystick
and when I say switch I mean from
session to session to so on different
days what's sort of interesting is that
we saw this the same sort of rate with
the header a with uninsured subjects but
we saw much lower percentage of switch
with the joystick so this suggests that
perhaps there's also an element of
difficulty in this that where for spinal
cord injured subjects there's always a
certain level of difficulty because of
their injury whereas with uninjured
subjects the
he needs to be introduced by the
interface there's one possible possible
explanation okay we also saw a few
differences between subject groups and
this kind of surprised us so in
particular we saw the greatest
difference between subject groups in
terms of command fluency which was a
metric we computed that basically just
looked at how fluent the users commands
are and this makes sense right that
people with spinal cord injury the way
that they're interacting with the
interface is very different but in terms
of what actually gets executed because
it's being run through our system as a
whole that has autonomy helping out we
end up seeing very few differences on
the whole an actual the absolute view
was actually distance to obstacles which
is sort of a safety measure one other
thing that we sell which is another
publication that's currently under
review is that we tried to look at
whether or not we could model and
predict people's preference based on
computable metrics now these computable
metrics are not just metrics we
typically use in robotics so it's not
just performance metrics like distance
or like time completion time it's also a
lot metrics that have to do with how the
human is interacting with the machine
and that we did find that we could
compute I mean it's it's pretty good
it's certainly not perfect but that
starts to give us an idea that if we
wanted to be able to sort of adapt to
this over time that perhaps it is
something that we would be able to do
measure for example how many sort of
commands they had to we did so that's
one of the metrics that we had was a
number of interface interactions and now
I'm kind of grouping under a performance
so when I say performance I'm kind of
making the assumption that fewer
interface out interactions are better
but there's also things like you can
look at the sort of like signal
frequency you can look at this fluency
things like that as well yeah okay so
going back to this slide I've just
basically showed you how we can have
different formulations for how to how to
actually like formulate that the control
sharing but I haven't really talked
about tuning the parameters yep and
that's what I'm going to talk about in
this next study so we also we explored
with our robotic arm a study of end-user
customization so this is just an
exploratory study we had four subjects
with spinal cord injuries and thirteen
subjects without and they were operating
our robotic arm so we have one of those
canova arms we've d'amico naka Jago
and we were using this sort of linear
control blending paradigm actually an
uncle dragon who i believe spoke earlier
this week she had a paper where she did
a literature review of these sort of
control sharing or assisted paradigms
and in that literature hbu she found
that a lot of the paradigms actually
take this functional form roughly so and
of course this functional form has three
parameters so one is at what point do
you start providing assistance then how
quickly do provide it as the slope and
then at the end when you're really
confident with your ability to in like
infer the intent of the human actually
how much how much control lives with the
human versus autonomy so when I'm really
confident does the human still have
thirty percent of the control do they
have 20 percent of the control things
like that now one thing we didn't look
at is that whether or not this should be
anything else so arguably even if the
robots really confident that it knows
what the humans trying to do that
doesn't necessarily mean that it should
take over a lot of the control it might
be a factor of like tesc difficulty or
other things and one of my students
Siddharth is now looking into different
things to have along the x-axis but that
wasn't a part of this study so what we
did in this study I mentioned that it
was exploratory and so of course you can
get different functional forms if you
have different parameterizations now we
wanted people to be able to parameter or
funk like customize this function but of
course we didn't want to just show them
the function and say change this right
so what we did we just have people
verbally telling us how they'd like it
to change like I wanted the autonomy to
come in sooner and so that would mean
that we should move this right where I
wanted the autonomy to help me out
faster which means the slope should be
super things like that so this is fuzzy
but this was exploratory here's an
example of what it looks like to be
operating this robotic arm without
assistance so here he's operating at I
believe as a two-axis joystick he
doesn't have the hand function to twist
now right here when we when we partition
the control space into these different
control modes you need a way to switch
between them as this robot is sold
commercially you switch it with a button
press now he doesn't have the finger
function to actually push a button so
he's wearing a utility cuff he is a pen
inside of it and that's how he's
actually switching the switching the
control mode which brings up another
challenge with this sort of operational
paradigm is that you actually need to
remember what control mode so you see
here he switch
it actually wasn't in the control mode
that he thought it would be so you need
to remember what control mode not just
what you're currently in and what the
one is you want to get to about how many
button presses it takes to get there and
maybe not overshooting sudden he finally
gets to UM gets to the control mode he
wanted and he is able to he's trying to
get the spoon into the bowl so now
here's what it looks like with
assistance running so one of the things
to really notice he actually doesn't
need to provide any any mode switches
now that's partly a factor of being in a
control mode to start out with that's
informative right so if I've got two
objects in front of me and I'm in a
control mode where I can operate along
this axis it's very informative for me
to move along this access in terms of
which object I'm trying to get to if for
example I was in a control mode instead
that did rotation wouldn't tell me
anything about which object i'm going to
and that's actually something that my
student Deepak is starting to work out
is actually doing these sort of
automatic mode switches in ways that
help to sort of maximally inform the
robotics autonomy to help disambiguate
the human intent yeah confidence it is
um but it's not really playing a role at
in that um well yeah no it is so and so
for example in the in the video I showed
with the two doorways it was it was a
factor of the things i mentioned before
where it's the humans control signal and
also the distance and heading of the
robot or distance from the goal it's
also also included in that confidence is
our perception confidence so if for
example we were only seeing the door
once in every ten frames we be we
wouldn't necessarily be confident that
we even know that store in the first
place versus if we're seeing it you know
nine nine out of ten frames and we're
much more confident and so that actually
plays a role too but how to actually
formulate this like confidence of your
intent inference also is a research area
this picture here the there's only two
it's just they're just these two bowls
right here and so and for manipulation
we so manipulation in the one hand is
easier than then the wheelchair because
your work space is limited by the size
of your arm and so
if you can just perceive what's in the
space of where you can actually reach
that's all you need to consider whereas
a wheelchair can reach sort of anywhere
and so anything that's possibly in your
perceptual view is an option now what's
harder about the robotic arm is that
what you actually do once you have a
goal is a lot more varied we do a lot of
different types of things with our hands
and arms or as the wheelchair just kind
of needs to drive somewhere and arrive
with a certain heading and not hit
things and so there it's different the
two problems are different in terms of
what's more challenging the confidence
need not be over the ultimate goal it
doesn't right which is probably actually
the right thing to do unless you're
going to have a solution that's
basically autonomous and someone says
like take me to the kitchen if you're
trying to infer it like if you're trying
to infer from me giving as a control
signal like this whether I want to go
out that door or like go down that
street there's no way to do it and you
wouldn't perform any differently in
achieving those goals anyways the
sub-goals along the way so it's
generally better to just reason about
the supples more immediately yeah they
are so these are all high spinal cord
injury but you know they're they're
partial such a partial spinal cord it
was called an incomplete spinal cord
injury otherwise he wouldn't have any
hand function and in this case these
people I mean did we all we all everyone
we've had come to the lab has some arm
and hand functions so it's not getting
all the way up into the neck but
normally even then they do because
respiration the reason why the sip and
puff is an interface is because the
respirations often the last one to go
and so the last of capability to go and
so they they all had speech they I
shouldn't say I should clarify they all
had zero speech impairment it wasn't
just that they all could speak we have a
little bit so I've got a one student who
and I don't have it in this talk but
I've a collaboration with on with Tom
Howard at the University of Rochester
reverse rat who works in speech for
robots and national language for robots
and we're starting to consider it so of
course it could be extremely powerful
it's obviously it's also much more
ambiguous than like just operating it in
her face like this so there's trade-offs
so I think that you know the right
solution is probably gonna be a mixture
certainly the give
high level goal voice is better right
for to be able to say go to the kitchen
rather than for it from my current
velocity command right so they're
actually used to be about 20 years ago
that there was a commercial voice
recognition product well and and it was
dangerous so basically it would got
trained on people just talking normally
and then when people needed to act in an
emergency situation they used a
different tone of voice so they would
shout stop right and it wouldn't
recognize that so it was dangerous so
while voice recognition systems are used
widely like to operate computers they
don't operate physical machines now
obviously voice recognitions gotten a
lot better you can maybe ask for things
like conformation you can maybe also do
it for more like meta characteristics of
execution to say something like go
faster right and and do higher level
things but two issued like the lower
level sings to constantly say like go
forward go forward that's probably not
where you want to do it so I think it'll
probably be kind of like a partitioning
yeah yeah exactly we're not there yet
yep yep the assistant system would
actually take specific actions that's
not in this study but that's actually
something that my student deepak we
currently have it under under submission
and so we haven't done the study out
with subjects that we've just formulated
it and then done a little like pilot
work but the idea is that if you could
sort of do it's sort of like a help me
help you scenario right like if you are
willing to operate in this control mode
i'll be able to provide you with help
much earlier because i'll know what
you're trying to where you're trying to
go yeah yeah
there is the option of the voice control
anguish right right and then of course
there's also CC eye cream mmm yeah
sometimes but even if the individual
doesn't have that is a possibility and
once we get to brain computer interfaces
that are really really robust and really
like just another commercial option I
think that'll be a game-changer in these
domains I do think the tech that like
getting to that point is probably from
what I've heard it's not my area but
from what I've heard from clinicians at
Ric we're probably 15 years away so it
doesn't mean that we shouldn't be
working on other stuff in the meantime
it's also different so for operating a
wheelchair they've already shown that
you can just use sort of like skull
based EEG signals and that's because
it's just a much more discreet like
control space let's find just the
sub-goals it might be sufficient only to
get a few yeah you don't all use a
microphone right well except to get I
mean so so for example the people have
been able to operate a robotic arm with
b/ci are only using implantable
implantable chips okay right so yes so
sorry so I didn't realize I mean I know
you would just mention voice but like I
don't really do you would switch back so
I was just answering the BCI part so
it's true for Boise you could do that
one of the challenges with that is that
other people can hear it and in terms of
people sort of like appearing and player
impaired and it's an overloaded control
channel so it's the sort of thing one of
the I know that one of the things that
therapists and people don't like about
using the sip and puff is that you can't
carry on a conversation when you're
walking with someone else at the
wheelchair for example so those would be
would be considerations but it's
certainly it's technologically feasible
I agree absolutely
you know that so i guess i am worth it
like drew back Mel's been doing pci work
it also related to that i was curious
you doing mr. earlier but what is the
strip type of technical approaches are
using compared to the work that they
stated you slap a story not try to do in
tech are commissioned and yeah that's
really interesting results unlike people
sort of times reacting badly to autonomy
taking over right right so so at least i
don't know about so i know that some of
shervin's work like they didn't react
well i know that in many much of SIDS
work they're actually their way of like
estimating intent is actually just based
on distance so i would say a patent
possibly like some of that rejection is
maybe because it's not a rich enough
it's not taking into account enough
factors which which i should say is that
like something was simple like distance
is actually what a lot of the rest of
the field was doing as well so it might
be that it just needs to be sort of more
rich more richly like formulated i would
say that i mean in terms of just sort of
basing it on confidence and stuff like
that that's something that certainly
said a group is doing and and others in
the field as well this sort of estimate
of your confidence and intent and burn
so in that sense it's very similar but
yeah I'd say actually the fact that that
that the fact that that control sharing
like diagram or if the model is like
probably overly simplistic and
especially about what's on the excess
access is overly simplistic i think is
something that as a field we need to be
working on yeah alright so um so sort of
some results from this this this
exploratory study that we da one thing
that was interesting is that the
differences between that we saw between
spinal cord injured and subjects and
uninsured so here the red is the spinal
cord injured subjects blue or black is
uninjured here we have a task completion
time so we're looking at performance in
that regard and then here we have
teleoperation we have sort of a minimum
amount assistance and a maximum amount
of assistance and then custom is that
what they were able to customize and it
lies somewhere in between min and Max
the within the constraints so one thing
that was interesting is that at is that
we see that the sort of like
statistically significant different
between the subject group sort of
declines with assistance type but it
still exists that Max and we're
providing as much assistance as we can
we still see statistically significant
difference between these populations but
we don't once they've customized so that
kind of suggests to us that there's
something else going on and we're not
we're not we're not entirely sure yet
this is an exploratory study but we
thought that was interesting another
thing that was interesting was that
spine so we had two phases of
customization and we saw that spinal
cord injured subjects customized for
more assistance and uninsured subjects
customized for Less assistance now of
course we only did two rounds so if we
did a bunch around these maybe would
have sort of like normalized to sort of
the same point or like reached a steady
state but at least for this first
initial just one round and then a second
round we saw that difference we saw a
suggestion that actually user directed
optimization was considering something
more than what we normally see in sort
of standard cost functions that are used
within robotics so in particular we saw
seven of 34 customizations had a greater
task completion time so that would
suggest that they were not minimizing
time which we often do in robotics
objective functions and 14 and 34
customizations have more mode switches
which would be it which would sort of
relate to effort minimization because
you need to physically push that button
to switch that mode and we saw that
people were not always minimizing for
that either and also when we consider
the two of them together we also can't
explain all the data so that suggests
that there's something else going on we
don't know what it is but something else
and then in the interest of time I think
I am going to skip that video actually
we're kind of done okay so actually I
didn't yeah okay so I'm actually going
to just just mention one one small part
so fuschia work is adaptation so we kind
of talked about sort of changing these
adaptations over time and when that
really comes to is the actual title of
my talk so I'm gonna actually skip
through all this okay this comes from
the to the title of my talk which is
actually this robot learning from motor
impaired teachers and task partners so
we always have a human in the control
loop and that's an opportunity to use
learn from them but of course we have
all of these challenges in learn
from them that I mentioned earlier right
the information they're giving us is
filtered through their motor impairment
and through the interface that they're
forced to use and we might be trying to
use that map that information to control
a more complex machine as well so this
question of what the domain of robot
learning from motor and paired teachers
looks like when we have all of these
challenges is a big unknown and so in
particular if we're saying how to adapt
so this is some prior work I did during
my postdoc where we actually had a
tactile interface to perform adaptation
for the human to give corrections to the
robot that's not going to be a viable
option in this domain most likely
because motor impairments are the reason
why there is assistance and so exactly
how to perform the adaptation once we
actually even have the signal is it
going to be a big question so as
everyone in this room knows I mean
unless you're working in unsupervised
learning domains you need some sort of a
signal whether it's a reward signal
whether it's an example and exactly
where those signals come from is a big
question and then there's also a
question of how do we actually define
these in the first place so if a human
wants to actually now define something
from scratch here I'm trying to define a
trajectory for a robot robotic arm that
has 15 degrees of freedom and there's
just no interface that really does it
for you that's sort of like a standard
joystick interface so what we had to do
was outfit my arm in hand with a bunch
of sensors in order to get that example
data so what do examples look like in
this domain of having limited interfaces
and motor impairments is going to be
another big question as well and as I
actually as I mentioned in the beginning
of the talk I we have a we have a big
grant right now that wherever we are
going to be trying to suss this out and
see if we need to develop new algorithms
or if it's just that we need to sort of
reformulate existing algorithms to
expect this kind of data and perform
well with this kind of data okay um so
what do you think what five minutes okay
so this this last one that I'm going to
talk about also in the context of robot
learning is this idea of human learning
as well so actually what would be the
gold standard of all of these sorts of
tools is if operating the assistive
device had motor learning benefits and
so this would be that the so the idea
would be that you know we someone has an
injury or disease we do as much as we
can for them in rehabilitation because
we want them to regain as
their own ability if they get to if
there's a gap then and they can't get
all the way to being fully capable we
introduce assistive machines if we
introduce assistive machines with
autonomy they can help out more
effectively or at least that's the idea
what would be great is that when using
that assistive machine in autonomy you
actually also can continue to help with
the rehabilitation process and step the
person closer to relying on that machine
less or or perhaps not at all so one
idea that we have within a collaborator
at at Ric is Sandra Musa Valdi and he
has developed this interface now this is
sort of an exception to what I said
earlier that we are only using
commercially commercial interfaces his
group has developed this interface
called the body machine interface and
what this is is actually a vest of I'm
use that's one on the shoulders and they
take these these sort of
high-dimensional signals so if you've
got four I amuse you get a 36
dimensional signal and they're mapping
it down to a 2d signal and they use that
to control a wheelchair or to control a
to be due point on a screen that you can
type in a virtual keyboard you can play
a game of pong and this is even for
people who are quadriplegics so people
with very high spinal cord injury you
often if it's incomplete you often have
a very tiny bit of motion left in the
shoulders and this machine the system
can pick that up on that and actually
then use it effectively what's nice
about it is that you have to move to
operate the interface so it actually
potentially has rehabilitation benefits
and they have currently have an ro1
where they're doing a clinical trial to
actually see the extent to that benefit
I would say that's also in contrast to
the brain computer interfaces is that
well this system certainly is not going
to be as rich as BCI systems eventually
will be BCI systems also don't
necessarily have any physical motor
motor rehabilitation benefit so so far
they've used this to operate a 2d system
what we would like to do is use it to
operate a 60 system now we don't even
know if this is possible certainly when
I think of like how I could operate in
high dimensions with my shoulders like I
can think really easily of four
dimensions I don't know if six would be
like introducing cross terms I don't
know and so it's unclear whether or not
people are even going to be able to
disambiguate that but what our plan is
to do is have robotics autonomy help
with that learning process so the idea
is that if we start out with the 60
control signal and we have the human
operating just two dimensions in the
robotics autonomy operating the rest
just like
saw on some of the other work in my talk
that the autonomy could be kind of
monitoring monitoring the humans
performance and as the person becomes
more more capable you unlock an
additional control to mention i should
mention that so far Sandra has been
using PCA which on the one hand seems
like you know an older machine learning
technology but I'd say I'd argue in this
domain it's actually quite elegant
because what they do first just have to
have someone do what they call a a body
motion calibration dan something like
that but they have someone they have the
subjects move in all the dimensions that
they can as much as they can and then
they use that that defines like the
variance of their mobility right so if
now you're taking the vectors along
which you have the highest variance it
makes a lot of sense from a motor
learning rehabilitation standpoint so
the idea is that you can unlock an
additional control dimension and in
doing that then humans taking over more
control than the robotics autonomy and
hopefully eventually we get to the point
where maybe we don't have that time or
if we do it can if we can't get to that
point then you know the autonomy can
still play them stay in place in the
humans at least moving to operate this
machine and perhaps regaining the more
control over the machine over time and
so okay so and so what we really like
about this idea is that we're actually
using robot machine learning in order to
elicit human motor learning hopefully
that's idea this is just a proof of
concept that integrated the two systems
so this is just the person here is just
issuing a 2d control signal one
dimensions controlling the speed of the
robot trajectory the second dimension is
controlling excuse me the transitions
between the piecewise trajectories so
how we just transition here to reaching
to grasping and then grasping to
carrying and lenta pouring each of those
transitions got triggered by the body
machine interface you'll notice that
he's his movements are really big that's
because he has a no motor impairment and
because of that because of that body
calibration dance it's actually
encouraging you to move within the full
space of where he has motor capabilities
so this is just a proof of concept that
the few systems could be integrated and
I'm going to skip all this stuff so
sorry
okay so just to sort of summarize talked
a lot about these different kind of
control challenges that we see in this
domain and the idea is that we can
introduce autonomy and the big question
there is and how do you share control
with the human but then we had this
additional factor where people have
unique and non-static abilities and this
actually needs to play into the design
of the autonomy and once we start
considering that there's a question of
how do you actually customize this to
each person and also where do these
learning signals come from once we
actually start to introduce long-term
adaptation over time so that's my talk
I'd like to thank my lab members of
course and we have a great lab space at
the rehabilitation Stooges taco for the
next month before we move into new
hospital but I encouraged if anyone's in
Chicago please feel welcome to stop by
yeah can you say more about how you
formulate that human learning objective
like how it does the machine yes yeah so
that's certainly not my area Sandro has
expertise in in that and actually one
thing I didn't mention one thing that
the the grant that we've proposed to
study this actually would try to look at
it and the only sort of space that we're
trying to look at it in is actually how
we should be unlocking the additional
control dimensions so you should you
could imagine that you start out with
the strongest control dimensions where
they have the most capability and then
unlock weaker ones as they come become
more capable or you could start out with
the weakest and kind of force them to
work in the space that's hardest and
unlock it in that direction so that's
that's where motor learning comes into
our study and then we'll do kind of a
pilot study to sort of see what what
sort of range of parameters we have we
have a couple of different parameters in
terms of how quickly we add up the robot
and like having a slow rate of
adaptation and a fast rate just to start
to see if there's differences between
people but you know within this initial
study we aren't going to be able to dig
into it too deeply it'll really be you
know exploring a lot of it will be
exploring the space and Sandra has nose
like the background field on what human
motor look or learning looks like I do
not yeah
we'll take the rest of the questions
during coffee break and thank you for
them
[Applause]